Michael mehar t-rob hey Larry what's up
what's up dude we're gonna do an
unboxing of this xbox one halo 5 bundle
sweet we're gonna have fun got console
in here and everything yeah not LOL
anything yeah right first up let's dive
right in we got this metal case like
halo 2 is member the special edition for
those always came right I can taste good
I definitely purchase that when I was
younger batteries um right off the bat
we have what is this mike uh oh right
this is from Lasky commander Lasky of
the UNSC infinity the ship from Halo 4
that was built in everything that you're
kind of on all the time it's just like a
like a military order to Jameson Locke
and team Osiris to just pretty much fire
on sight if they see chief or anyone you
know like a whole hunt the true thing
halo 5 you're chasing at the chief
playing as a chief kind of bounces back
and forth and I guess this is just kind
of adding some story some Laura to the
whole thing some lore yep kill kill kill
yeah here we have you got some like bio
cards here here we have um I believe
this is a metal guardian these are I've
never done one of these but they seem
very intense this is a 3d laser cut
model I have done these before and kind
of a geek but yeah like you need needle
nose pliers most of times they got these
little tabs I mean these ones look super
complicated but it turns out once you're
finished this it'll be a guardian you
also get for a low online or GTA
multiplayer you get the photos class
armor and a multi-player emblem
obviously you get the game which
relations october twenty seven twenty
seventh as a digital download you also
get a agent Locke controller now you
know well his visors blue and the
buttons of blue so that's cool this is a
nice controller I think that's a vessel
tossing you know reminds me the Halo
Reach controllers that came with that
bundle way back in a 2010 kind of a
match the console and the game again
and now we'll take a look at doctors
obviously you get power cord hdmi
headset works there there's a one
terabyte storage in this right on soul
and that height because we all like
storage and here we go here's the big
big kahuna the xbox one it also sort of
looks like the controller the lot they
manage yeah pretty cool cool I'm like we
are not done yet we're not we have
something else that is not all see if we
can clear some space we'll see what we
can do here alright cuz this is pretty
small box so we don't need a lot of
space for it at all it's pretty much
taking up the entire camera frame
hopeful you can still see me while we're
talking we'll just gently put those
things down right so what is this rob
hmm you know it looks like another halo
hot purchase so Mike we were opening
this thing up there is no xbox in this
guy but again it is whipped with your
halo 5 and everything that was in the
case here Oh kind of weird shaped box
will figure this out she is same thing
same deal tin case again whoa didn't
work out well uh yeah so this is pretty
big actually he's like 12 inches tall
they both are well I guess a cord like
based on the lure seems accurate chief
is taller than walk he's a superhuman
pretty much which lock is kind of just a
new Spartan yeah less expensive to make
actually it turns a lure for those you
who care about that stuff again like me
it's cool pretty tight
so again this is a collector's edition
comes with a statute and the game and
everything that we went over and it runs
for 249 yep and halo 5 guardians
released October 27th gamespot we will
have our review up Monday morning before
that October 26th which i will be
reviewing robs have been helping me out
playing campaign and whatnot and yeah
we'll have some more thoughts on that
you know on our live shows and once a
game releases yeah for all your gaming
halo needs good gamespot com